check out the story from the post
millennial Michigan house makes using
wrong pronouns a felony the bill makes
it a felony for someone to make an
individual quote feel terrorized
frightened or threatened and is
punishable by up to five years in prison
and ten thousand dollar fine
they say uh they write on Tuesday
Michigan state has passed a bill making
it a felony HB 4474 is designed to
replace Michigan's ethnic intimidation
act to expand categories of protected
classes to include identity gender
identity expression and sexual
orientation and it passed 59-50 it is
not yet law but I guarantee you
guarantee
we will see if this passes I'm not sure
so sure that it will but maybe I mean
it's Michigan you got you know I think
whitmer's still there right you will see
people arrested for this and you know
why I I have absolute confidence in
saying that because Jordan Peterson
warned us how much was it seven or eight
years ago and then in Canada we have
seen several instances where people have
been criminally charged for using wrong
pronouns I imagine this violates some
sort of free First Amendment issue like
you can't tell me what I can and can't
say to you
that's my right to say whatever I want
there might be you know I'm not saying
that the person's not going to throw a
punch if I if I anger them and then
they'll go to jail or whatever but
that's like the essence of this nation
the Supreme Court ruled on 303 creative
uh this this uh Christian web designer
who said under Colorado's
anti-discrimination laws uh I feel as
though my I would be compelled to make
wedding websites for same-sex couples if
they approach me about it and I don't
think that's fair and one of the things
that came up in the decision today was
uh the justices wrote Colorado under the
interpretation of the law Colorado
currently has they would compel this
woman into speech that she doesn't agree
with and so it's kind of similar to what
you're saying I wonder if in some way
there is already legal precedent that
you know this is Michigan so they can't
necessarily take Colorado law but if we
have federal law that says you can't
compel speech like at what point do you
prioritize the First Amendment maybe
they would what they're saying with this
is that if you it's like I'm pretty sure
the bill is specifically about in the in
the act of committing a crime if you do
this thing it's a it's a it's um what do
they call it like a hate crime thing
it's a hate crime thing but it's um it's
uh I forgot what it's called in law when
they add on to the crime because of a
thing you did I forgot I'm I'm I can't
do it right now yeah
yeah like a secondary offense I think is
what they call it like you can't get
pulled over for something or something
once you get pulled over there yeah I
mean it's bad it's a bad precedent but I
think it was Nuance bro who's talking
he's like it's it's kind of comparable
to the lynching bills it's like well
lynching's already illegal it's already
illegal to
harass people it's already illegal to do
these things in this bill
to make someone feel terrorized yeah
that's not up to me the way you feel is
the way you choose to feel I'm not my
words are not making you feel anything
I'm making noise and you are
interpreting that and making yourself
feel a certain way we will see someone
arrested for this yeah me I'm probably
gonna get arrested for this I'm gonna
yell you know Governor Whitmer and call
her a boy and go to jail can't go to
Michigan anymore no they'll say that you
were you were right wing Tara and all
that stuff can you get arrested for it
or is it just an additional charge that
you would get or it makes the charge
more severe if you're also misgendering
them like I think this in and of itself
is a hate crime to make someone feel
terrorized frightened or threatened by
misgendering them well in any way it
literally I don't think it's specifies
to make someone feel afraid intimidate
means willful course of conduct
involving repeated or continuing
harassment of another individual that
would cause a reasonable individual to
feel terrorized frightened or threatened
and that actually causes the victim to
intimidate does not include
constitutionally protected activity or
conduct that serves a legitimate purpose
well constitutional protected activity
is calling a man a woman that's right
but apparently not no it is
so there that will be up for the courts
but we are we are Marching the direction
so look
Jordan Peterson this is his big thing
was it bill c16 or whatever it was back
in the day he was like what's the next
thing he's like people go to jail for
this they all mocked him and they said
you're lying they were like Dr Peterson
the penalty is a fine and then he goes
and what happens if you don't pay the
fine and everyone's like
oh
you go to jail and he's like oh so what
did I say that was wrong
and then sure enough we've seen it there
was like one guy who wouldn't call his
daughter male pronouns so they arrested
him or something like that what is that
Canada let me see if uh let me see if I
find that we had a member uh one night
that was afraid to say anything bad
about Trudeau because he was a Canadian
and he's like I can't like you guys can
make the jokes but I won't make any
jokes here on your after show Danny
polish shook doesn't even make that
money it's the Trudeau jokes and he's 20
21. he's like 20 21 father arrested for
discussing child's gender transition and
Defiance of court order
oh I mean you know why would a teenager
was born female and he was uh kept
referring to her with the look at this
look at the New York Post wrote
referring to his teen daughter uh
referring to him with the pronouns she
and her born female okay New York Post
that he was found in contempt of court
and arrested Tuesday for calling his
calling the teen his daughter and
publicly referring to him with the
pronouns she and her the teenager was
born as a female and that's in Canada
yep that's already happening here though
in California they want it to be child
abuse if you don't affirm your child's
exactly I'm telling you it is it is we
got real everybody got really mad at
Target for the tug friendly bathing suit
but then when you really looked at it
their marketing of VP was giving you
know 2.1 million dollars to glisten
which actually you know is a corporation
that helps kids transition behind their
parents back but you know so they really
are I mean they're not secretive about
them out in the open they've been part
partnered with organizations like that
for like over a decade though Target is
one of the headline sponsors for New
York City's youth pride and was one of
the founding sponsors of New York City
youth Pride so it wasn't just I'm just
surprised it took this long for people
to realize but I think the northern
tentacles were reaching I think the
narrative around pride in these
organizations shifted over time like
over the last decade it went from being
like you're gonna come out to your
parents and they're not going to accept
you and you need a chosen family who
will embrace you and love you to being
like you're going to tell your parents
that you want to undergo medical
intervention surgery to alter your your
sexual characteristics and they're going
to say no and that's terrible and you're
gonna have to look for people to support
you like the conversation has
dramatically shifted as uh our our left
Progressive counterparts have embraced
gender ideology it's the Bolsheviks
they took the ownership of children
imagine a court ordering you
to not refer to your own daughter as a
as your daughter
and he got arrested for it this is back
in uh
uh 2021 March I think it was
yeah and so yeah like in California
they're they're passing that bill that
says you have to affirm your kids
otherwise it's child abuse they'll take
your kids from you no no compelled
speech laws I don't like that I mean
affirming the kid isn't necessarily a
speech thing because if they if they
start making you compelling you to say
something then they can make you
say things about your leader and no
that's I mean this is
a specific thing the Supreme Court just
ruled on yesterday that we shouldn't be
that state laws shouldn't compel you to
do something that violates your yours
the way you would otherwise speak but
again they're dancing the line they're
they're sort of saying like well we're
not saying that you can't say something
we're just saying that will punish you
if you don't say this other thing well I
think the dad was really disappointed
because if you notice in this particular
situation this was a female to male
transition giving them no advantage in
sports now if this is the other way
around where it was a male transitioning
to a female maybe she would have been a
great athlete like Leah Thomas and then
he would have been more proud of her
maybe it's only that maybe it's on the
dad that's what I'm saying I think it's
the dad's fault
the father was trying to find Medical
Solutions that didn't involve drugs and
they were they were like nope drugs
yeah wow well that's the thing Tim they
literally this has happened with the
Chloe Cole they'll tell the children's
parents that the child is going to kill
themselves if they do not get this
gender firming surgery when in actuality
the assistance rights are between like
65 and 98 so your best
opportunity the best course of action
seeming for the child this is what
Europe found is nothing yeah
non-intervention not intervention and
when they say stuff like if you don't do
this you will take their own life or
harm themselves it's actually the
inverse
if if the suicidality uh ideation and
action is higher among the transgender
population but children are 60 to 90
likely to desist with no intervention
then intervention actually increases the
rate of of suicidality
yes we don't want to get medical
misinformation but ssris actually
increase your suicidal idolization well
I'll I'll keep it simply make sure you
find a good doctor you trust yes we're
just people on the internet okay I'm not
a doctor do not listen to anything from
me medically yeah so I'm I'm speaking
not not as a medical doctor who can talk
about I'm speaking my opinion based on
the studies showing decisions rates are
this high but uh so what I should say is
if those studies are true logic would
dictate the best course of action is X
but uh not a doctor you are to confirm
what you're saying Alex antidepressants
and suicide risk from the National
Institute of Health of 2005 systematic
review controlled trials compared to
ssris with other active treatments or
placebos found almost two-fold increase
in the odds of fatal and non-fatal
suicide acts
yeah National Institute of Health wow
that's the first thing that came up when
I typed SSRI suicide it's no joke and
I'm not a doctor at all but I'm telling
you not once during the pandemic that
they ever tell anybody to go get some
exercise eyes and eat better I mean
that's I think that's where it comes
down to a lot of our mental health
problems too is the crap that we eat and
we don't exercise and just because I'm
sure a lot of people are like what's on
SSRI it's a selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitor
there you go now you know what SRI
stands for the more you know serious
take Inhibitors well you've been working
out a lot how do you feel I feel better
knowing I I think that's like uh you
know for me I've had a challenging stuff
I lost my mom not that long ago and I
remember exercising and stuff because I
was very depressed about that that's the
only thing that made me feel better
um so I think if it helped me with that
it would help everybody else out and I
know it's not a placebo it's not just
going to fix problems with people that
exercise that are depressed but I'm just
saying there are natural remedies I
believe instead of just taking a magic
pill I've been doing a mile on the on
the bike on the assault bike and it's
like it lowers my blood pressure like I
was just working my lower body a little
bit of the upper body but afterwards for
like six hours I just have lower blood
pressure it's fantastic for my mind
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time